conversation hello welcome to game
Sports coverage of e3 2016 here to talk
about steep Ubisoft brand new IP we have
Rebecca studio head from Ubisoft annecy
hello Rebecca thank you for joining us
and of course Justin hey was I'm a
skateboarder extraordinaire Rebecca what
is it like to be able to speak and show
the world steep we've been waiting for
this moment for such a long time and
that's why I was laughing so much on
stage you know I haven't even been able
to talk about with my kids at home so
everybody we've been longing for this
state for a long time and we're just
overwhelmed it was so much joy in the
audience yesterday so yeah and the
feedback has been great so far so we're
very happy it's like being in the the
CIA do your kids try to like sneak into
your computer to find things I'm like oh
I know what mom's working on no because
they knew that we the studio we were
working on the division and Ghost Recon
wildlands so we've had a lot of
discussions about that at home but this
is our passion and I really wanted to
share it so I spoke to them this morning
and they went oh that game is really
really great mama so what were the
inspirations where did the what the idea
come from for steep okay so we are
surrounded by mountains and the passion
in the studio is really the mountains
whether it's paragliding or whether it's
skiing or snowboarding of course it's
not wingsuit because the sport so we've
been waiting to make this game for a
long time and then we saw the technology
for Ghost Recon wildlands that is set in
Bolivia where a lot of mountains and we
thought hmm this is really interesting
so we started to take a look at that
technology and then we had an old
prototype in one of our drawers with a
jet ski and water and the physics of
that prototype was very good so we
actually took the go stricken technology
put that together with the proto we had
on on the jet ski in the water and the
marriage was great so we go to proto
functioning very quickly and of course
you guys have a lot of experience
working with multiplayer games and
creating those kind of experiences yeah
it's really our DNA on the studio we
started off with a multiplayer on
Splinter Cell and then we moved on to
the multiplayer on Assassin's Creed
where we did four iterations up to Black
Flag we learned a lot
so yeah it was a very good experience so
this is the first gaming studio has
taken point on then this is our first
game as the lead studio yes and we are
very proud is is that hard making their
transition from being kind of a support
to taking center stage yes and no
because there are so many Ubisoft is a
big machine and there were a lot of
things that we were not familiar with
because that had been managed by the
other lead studio on division or AC so
yes we're learning but we're very well
surrounded by our colleagues so it's
fine
so you had the prototype the jet ski and
they got in the wildlands mountains mush
together it worked how did the approval
process kind of work like was it
immediate like or did they say gonna
make some changes here or was it just
always your baby it was always our baby
and we've had a lot of support Wow yeah
so I mean let's talk a little bit about
what you'll actually be doing in the
game it's very multiplayer focus you're
not just gonna be playing by itself you
can if you want to and there are a
system of quests as you go from one
episode to the other and there will be a
very tiny narrative story mode where we
will explain the different mythix of the
mountains so you can't play alone but of
course you will have so much more fun
playing together and sharing that
experience are these based on real
places or are you just inspired by the
world around
oh it's real places we have had to
change them because you cannot ski on
all phases of Mont Blanc and we want the
player to be able to play everywhere in
the mountain so we had to do some
adjustment but if you know the Alps you
will recognize the tops of the mountains
immediately so I guess with that did you
guys get to do a lot of on-site scouting
and did you get to do a lot of traveling
for research well actually we don't need
to because we live in the mountains and
we spend all of her time in the
mountains the window yeah and we the
team goes skiing every Tuesday night and
we go skiing together on the weekends
and everything so of course we've done
some research but it's in our blood and
yeah see I had experience with skiing
what about like paragliding and
wingsuiting like
where did that kind of come from well so
we realized we've had this dream we
realized that we're not a lot of games
out there for a long time and we also
looked at what's happening on YouTube
with all the sharing and we thought wow
this is like people are sharing their
experience why shouldn't we be able to
do that in a video game so we started
off of course with the snowboarding and
the skiing and then we saw well people
love paragliding and people love
wingsuit so that's why we decided to go
for those sports as well what was the
GoPro culture kind of a an inspiration
for that at all as well of course and we
have a lot of GoPro people in the studio
that make their own videos and that
share them as well and we also think
that the the young generation coming up
having played with Minecraft this is
what they do you know they have their
YouTube channels and everything so we
think that that will be a great tool for
them as well to share their experience I
don't know if you saw yesterday the the
sharing that we have where you can zoom
out and zoom in and replay take your
screen shots and just put press the
share button so it's like as you go
through a run are you able to just like
stop and go back and look at where
you're at there and speaking of the
sharing is it just through the
PlayStation Share button or you guys
gonna have some kind of inbuilt social
network to kind of join all these
players together well well we have a
natural social network in the game
because the players will play together
but we will have more information on
that in the future so let's talk a
little bit about I mean like the camera
so you can see here we've got it like
really zoomed out we've got the GoPro
camera there any plans I mean it kind of
seems like that in VR would be kind of
cool mmm
that's a very interesting question of
course this deep experience in VR would
be perfect so this is something that we
are looking into but I cannot comment on
that today oh yeah in creating a
multiplayer experience like that when
when you have so many people coming
together it does it also tie into the
Ubisoft play or is this kind of
something where you want it to build
your own system like I know Ubisoft kind
of has its built in
yeah that works as well yeah no of
course we will work with you play and
the Ubisoft club and yeah it's more and
more games from Ubisoft oh of course a
multiplayer and community so it's it
yeah it's natural for us have you found
out that you're already getting people
like getting really excited getting
building that community already even
though you only announced yesterday
there must be people start at home going
this is what I do in real life I'm gonna
play this game we already had fun clubs
last night sharing the screenshots with
like 450 members in just a couple of
hours so yeah yeah happy I know wait and
we're sorry to interrupt you we have the
people have really been waiting for a
game like this so how big is the team
working on it
we are Anansie about 80 people mm-hmm
so you're still gonna have people
working on violence situation we're a
multi-product studio and we will work on
different brands it's a decision that
we've taken for the studio and I think
it's important because working on the
same brand for many years in a row it's
a it's a fatigue and people need
inspiration to be creative and to be
innovative so I want the team members to
have the possibility to change from one
brand to the other when they need to so
we will continue to be a multi brand
studio and does that breed a sense of
collaboration where people who are
working on one project might share ideas
and and say like this would be really
cool if you could integrate it somehow
into slate or another game you're
working on of course and so everybody in
the studio are very proud of steep even
though they're not working directly on
steep because they feel that they are
contributing as well by the learnings we
got on the division and by the learnings
that we're getting on the on go strike
and violence so everybody in the studio
very proud so when do you guys have a
like an estimated release date yet we
have we announced it yes although it's
for this December yeah and looking at a
game like this of course I think you you
said that people are gonna be highly
anticipating it was there any sense of
apprehension or a little bit of fear
once it once it goes out like Oh what if
what if people don't like something like
this or it was there any kind of that
apprehension of course
we have a saying in Swedish where we say
never say hello before you jump the
river and so of course of course we went
through you know it's a new brand it's a
new game and it's our baby and we've
been working on so hard and sometimes
you lose the distance we're looking at
all the assets and and everything so of
course you don't want to take out the
victory beforehand how long has it been
in development for two and a half years
two and a half years slowly how
difficult was it I mean a lot of games
this III especially have leaked ahead of
time how did you manage to keep this
under wraps mmm
I don't know I mean we were very so the
team was very small from the beginning
and we gradually ramped up when we
needed to and I think it I don't I don't
know why it didn't leak I mean there are
so many reasons for leaks but yeah we
kept it secret it wasn't that you ruled
with an iron fist and a huge NDA is that
were just destroy you ask my team lady
how did you get involved in Ubisoft
fantasy so I've been in the video game
industry since I shouldn't even say that
because I started in localization
testing in back in 95 and I started at
info Graham Satori back in 98 so I've
been in the video game industry for
quite a while and I joined Ubisoft five
years ago
and I had had some conversations with
them and they called me and asked if I
would take on this opportunity and I
went like wow of course it's a it's the
ancestor you multiplayer and AC and
everything so yeah you kind of have a
unique role it's not the kind of person
we tend to talk to we tend to talk to
creators and developers and what do you
do at the studio every day yeah I drink
tea no I work closely with the teams to
make sure that as I said early on what I
do I'm in meetings the whole time I
never take decisions we anticipate the
risks we assured that we have the right
people at the right spot we assure
because we're working with a lot of new
technologies you have to train the
people on the different technologies so
I assure that we have that I look into
the budget I calculate how much money we
spend it seems like there is a big
sharing culture at Ubisoft
with so many studios around the world
has there been that kind of support
network as well oh yeah of course
so we're working on the same
technologies go stricken wide LAN so of
course we do we share with the studios
working on that technology but the same
with the division we work on the
snowdrop technology with a couple of
other Studios like Red Storm of course
massive and as well as reflection so we
share technology there as well of course
wonderful record thank you so much for
joining us well thank you for having me
here
yeah very excited to see more steep and
it's coming out this December thank you
thank you for more coverage from this
year's e3 make sure of course you stay
tuned to game sport calm